>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good morning!
morning! Good morning!
(Applause.)
Good morning!
And welcome to a very, very
special day at the Library
of Congress, I'm Carla Hayden
and I can't tell you
how excited we are
because today we are celebrating
literacy and learning
and reading and we couldn't
ask for a better person
and organization to
collaborate with today.
Today our special guest is an
advocate for books and the power
of the written word
for children.
We are honored to have
here at the Library
of Congress multi award
win be philanthropist.
Dolly Parton.
I think it's time to clap!
I want to and I would be remiss
if I didn't introduce some
special guests in the audience,
the wonderful staff
and the leadership
of the Dollywood foundation,
led by Mr. David Dodson,
they have been wonderful
to work with!
There is Mr. Dodson.
We are delighted to have
members of Congress,
members of the Washington city
council, our various partners
in literacy and collaborators
and our generous donors who make
so much possible because today
we're all here as cheerleaders
for books and learning.
Now, I have to tell
you, when I started
as a children's librarian
I remember being inspired
by a young woman who was on
the south side of Chicago
and her name was Judy Zucher
and when I first walked
into that branch library she was
on the floor having story time
with children with ought simple.
simple. She was telling
stories and it's wonderful
where imagination and
reading can take you.
And today we have young
people who will join us
to have fun with books!
Ms. Dolly Parton has been
recognized many times
for her dedication to the
power of learning and for more
than two decades her imagination
library has helped hundreds
of thousands of children
worldwide,
giving them high-quality
books to own.
own. No matter what
their family's income
and in 2014 she was awarded
the Best Practices Award
from the Library of
Congress Literacy Foundation
so today we are pleased we
will be part of a milestone.
The Imagination Library is
about to give away their
100 millionth book,
that's so many I could barely --
100 millionth book
and we are humbled --
plagues applause that that
book will join with millions
of others at the
Library of Congress.
That book will be
given to us today.
So when the foundation
started 23 years ago,
the first books were distributed
to the Tennessee County
where Dolly grew up and now
it is a worldwide phenomenon.
So without further ado I would
like to share with you a video
about the Imagination Library.
[Video Plays]
(Applause.)
>> Now, please welcome,
multi award winning singer,
song writer and philanthropist,
Ms. Dolly Parton!
>> Hello!
(Applause.)
>> Thank you so much, hi there!
Wow, hi up there!
Well, it's nice to be here just
in this wonderful place, D.C. ,
and certainly here
in the Library
of Congress what a beautiful
building you have here?
>> It's been called the
most beautiful building
in Washington, D.C.
>> I think they're
probably right.
It's a beautiful day for us
and I'm so happy and excited
to be here and I was
watching the film back there
on the phone they had and
I was watching all that
and seeing how these
things have happened
through the years
I'm proud and honored
to be here today with you.
>> We're honored that you're
here because as you know
>> Did you want to sit?
>> Would you like to sit?
>> Why not?
>> They've seen us and they
know, because I'm interested
and I know a lot of our
guests are interested
in just how all of
this got started!
What inspired you
to create this?
This is such a great program.
>> Well actually, the whole
idea, the Imagination Library?
I guess everybody has their
story and a lot of you may
or may not know about
me personally,
but I grew up in the smoky
mountains of east Tennessee,
and I grew up in a very large
family, there were 12 of us kids
and my dad was a very
hard-working man,
he group up in a
family of 14 or 15 kids
and my dad never had a
chance to go to school.
And daddy not couldn't
read or write
but he was the smartest
person that I've every known.
He thought he couldn't learn
to read after he was grown,
it was just one of those
things and I had the idea
to do something special for
him, you know, in the Bible
where it talks about honor
your father and your mother,
I don't think that necessarily
means just to obey them,
I think it means to bring
honor to their name if you can.
So I got my daddy involved
with this little program.
I wanted him to feel like he
was part of something special.
So we started the
Imagination Library,
where we were giving books to
the children in our home county,
in Sevier County, where
we were born and raised.
We hoped it would do good there.
And it became such a popular
program that the governor
of Tennessee at that
time thought the idea was
so great they took it
all over Tennessee.
Later it went on into Canada
and now we're all over the world
in different parts of the world.
So my dad got to live
long enough to see a lot
of it come into being.
He took such pride in the fact
that the little kids
call me the "book lady."
He was prouder of
that than anything.
So it started from a true
place in my heart and it's done
so much good for so many
people through the years.
>> How does it feel to be
called the "book lady"?
You do so much, you sing
and write and everything
but you're known so
much as the "book lady.
Did you ever think you
would be the "book lady"?
>> No. That never crossed
my mind when I was growing
up because I personally
didn't like school!
I do more homework now at night
working on all these programs
than I every did all the
years that I was in school.
I never thought about being the
book lady, the painted lady,
yes, the over-exagerrated,
overdressed lady,
yes but that just goes to show
you, you can't judge a book
by looking at the cover!
Right? Or even the 100 Millionth
book by looking at the cover.
>> That's right, you can't tell.
You love books and reading,
so were there books
that shaped you?
You had favorite books?
>> Well, we didn't have books
in our home because there were
so many of us kids, and daddy
told us not to bring books home
because kids just chew
on them, pee on 'em,
and do whatever kids do,
so he said I can't afford
to you know pay for books.
So we didn't get to bring
books home but one book
in our home was the Bible and
my mother used to always read
from the Bible and
tell us Bible stories
so that was actually the first
book that we had in our home.
And the one that meant the most.
It has followed me more
than any other book
through my life, actually.
>> And you keep reading it?
>> I do. In fact
I love to read --
excuse me, I have
tissues, everywhere!
I need one right now!
But anyway I loved to read
and I do whatever it takes you
know...but I actually loved
anytime I was in school I
loved all the fairy tales,
I wanted to read all the books
about the Kings and the Queens
and all the traveling so books
have always been a really
special thing for me.
>> But with your busy schedule
how did you make time to read
because you were
still performing
and doing so many things?
>> I always take time to read.
I think for anybody
that does love
to read you will find
the time to read.
I do some of my best
thinking when I'm readin',
if you know what I mean.
I read probably at
least 52 books a year.
>> Wow!
>> A book a week I try to read.
So I've just always been a
reader, but there is a part
of my brain that kinda can think
of other things while
I am actually reading
but it does relax my body and
I have always loved to read
because I think in books,
I think with kids, too,
with the books that they read
it inspires you to dream,
and if you can dream,
that leads you
to success and to other things.
That's why I think it's so
important to get the books
in the hands of all
these special little kids
so they can start early
and go late with 'em!
>> And they love it.
So you make time for reading.
Does any of the reading help you
with some of your song writing
and some of the things
that you read about?
>> These are good
questions and yes, it does,
because I'm really inspired
by just people in general.
Just like the little
kids, a lot of things
that I write I have a children's
CD out called "I believe in you"
and a lot of the songs from
that were inspired by the books
that are in the Imagination
Library and the Little Engine
that Could is the
first book that we give
out in the Imagination Library
and I think it talks about how
to build confidence and
to know that you can
if you think you can
so I really am inspired
by just looking at
these faces today.
I will feel something
or think something
and who knows what idea it
might trigger in me later
on to write a song about.
When you write you go by
feelings and what touches you
and how it touches you
and you find a clever way
to put it into a song.
>> You mentioned that sometimes
the books can inspire feelings
and things in children
and I know
that you started the
library because you believed
in what books mean and
could mean to children.
I know I've seen it happen
and I've felt it as a child.
>> You of all people would know
because you've been doing
this for how many years?
You said long before you got
to this beautiful building!
>> Too long!
I remember the books that
inspired me when I was young
and you believe that, too?
>> Yeah, I do.
I really think that --
we're inspired by everything
and children themselves inspire
me and I'm sure they do you,
that's why you wanted
to work with children.
Because there is such a
world in every little child.
There is a whole world and
they're going to see it
and make things come true
in their little world
and they're going to add to the
world as they see fit according
to their talents and their
little personalities,
that's why it's so important
that they learn to love books
and learn to read and
be inspired by that.
Because just like with my
dad, My dad couldn't read
but he really was smart.
He picked up on things
and he was very intuitive.
It's my belief if you can read,
even if you don't have the money
to go to school, you can
especially anymore --
you can find a book, if you can
read, on anything that you want
to know, you can self-educate
yourself and go to college,
even, you can pick up
those kinds of books even
if you can't get outside your
house you can find a book
on any subject and you
can educate yourself
to where you can
know about things
and actually just increase
your intelligence and your --
just the whole world around
and you inspire other
people with that.
>> And what about owning a book
and saying this is my book!
It's got my name in it!
>> That's what I love about
the Imagination Library
because that was one of
the things we thought was
so important when
we first started it.
And so we wanted the little
children to have that book.
They get a book for those of you
that don't know the whole thing,
I guess they talked about some
of it, but children get a book
from the time they're born
they get a book a month
until they start kindergarten,
they're 5 years old,
so we send a book in the
mail with their name on it,
it's not in care of mom and dad
it's got their little name on it
and they love to
think this is mine!
They wait at the mailbox,
get their little book,
and to them it's personal.
So they're going to
take that in the house
and make somebody read it to 'em
because this is my
stuff, my stuff, my stuff!
(Laughter.)
>> So I think that has
been a real important thing
because they also share
it with other kids.
We're so happy we're
such a part of that
and of all the things
I have done in my life
and it's been a lot, because
I've been around a long time
but this is one of the
most precious things
and the proudest I
am of any program
that I've ever been involved
in in my life is working
with the little kids.
>> And you should be, because
after getting a book a month
they're going to have
their own little library.
>> Yeah, they do.
>> In their houses, this will
be their library and their books
and they can pull 'em out.
>> And they love that.
They love sharing
that with kids.
>> You mentioned, though,
that sometimes you get letters
that talk about what happens
after they're not
in the program.
>> Yeah, actually we get a lot
of letters when the kids are
in the program, we get letters
all the time from parents
and kids, but some of the
sweetest letters we get --
in fact I'll never forget
the first one I got was
from a little boy
that had graduated
from the Imagination
Library, he was 6 years old
and he was bummed out about it!
He was really mad
because he just wanted me
to continue to send him books!
He thought this is just not
fair, this is just not right
that I can't continue
to get my books!
That's how important
it is to them.
I wrote him back a sweet letter
and explained how we do it
and that's why -- he
was being prepared
because he was using his
mind to think about all that!
We get a lot of sweet letters
and we treasure every
one of them.
>> And then he can
get a library card.
>> Yeah! (Chuckles.)
>> Did you ever think
you would get
to 100 million books
when you started.
I mean that's phenomenal!
>> Not when we started.
Like I said, it was a very
personal thing when we started
and I just hoped it would
do good in in our county,
and then as I mentioned it
just grew and grew but at
that time it was something
I was doing for my dad
and the kids in our home county.
But thank the Lord, he was good!
And now we've got David
Dodson who is the President
of the Imagination Library,
stand up there for
a second, David!
(Applause.)
He works so hard and he makes me
look really good, I take a lot
of credit for a lot
of work that David
and all these wonderful folks at
the Imagination Library they do.
He travels all over
the world making sure
that all these wonderful
things happen,
making sure that all the things
that we brag about can happen.
I just get out and talk about it
and do my part but it's always
like that with anything
that you're proud of!
It takes a whole bunch of
people to make things happen
and we owe the real thing to the
communities and all the people
that participate,
all the organizations
that really get involved
and they're really the ones
that are making my
dreams come true.
It's just one of those things
that everybody takes
a lot of pride in.
Because if you're
doing something
with children how can you
not feel good about that!
Look at 'em?
Hi there! Hello!
So, anyway, it's a good
feeling all around,
it's a win-win as they say.
>> As I said, at the
beginning, we are so honored
that the 100 millionth book
will be given to the Library
of Congress for our youngsters.
>> We have an unveiling --
>> I want to say how
honored I am before we pull
that little thing up that
you have taken this to heart
and that you have taken this in
and that we will
now have this book
that I can actually
have here forever
for all the little children
all over the world certainly
in the United States
of America here
in D.C. It's a wonderful
place to have this.
Hopefully through the years we
have 100 million books so far
and maybe we will be back
for our billionth book,
wouldn't that be nice!
You want to see what's
under there?
>> It's a beautiful story,
there it is, 100 millionth book!
>> This is the coat
of many colors
which is a little story
-- this lady right here,
let me mention her name, this
is -- what's your name again?
(Laughter.)
>> This is the person who drew
>> Yeah, she illustrated
this book
and we appreciate your
name is Brook Hughes
and she illustrated
this and I hope you had
as much fun drawing this
as I did writing it.
>> I did, it was an honor
to be part of the project
and I loved getting to
illustrate your beautiful song.
>> Everybody loves it, this
song is important to me
because my mother -- I
was talking about my dad,
my dad was so very important
but my mother to have 12 kids
and make 'em all feel
special with no money,
she had all the love
in the world and it's
about the little story about --
she told me the story
about Joseph and the coat
of many colors when she was
making me a little raggedy coat
that I really needed because
it was getting wintertime
and I needed it.
So made that and she
just had the foresight
to give me some pride in it.
To tell me the story about
the coat of many colors
so this book is more than a
story and it's more than a song,
it's about love,
it's about attitude,
and actually it's turned out
to be an antibullying book.
They use this in some classrooms
to talk about antibullying,
and I want kids to
know it is okay for you
to be how you are
and who you are.
It's good to be different.
We can't all be the
same but we have we have
to love the differences
and accept the differences
in each other too.
So that's kind of what
this little book is about.
It's just about love
and understanding.
Thank you.
>> And thank you.
I see you have the coat here.
>> This little coat is a
replica of the little coat
that my mom made for me
because momma used to -
people used to send us big boxes
of scraps because momma used
to make all our clothes
and the quilts for our bed
and the curtains
for our windows,
and she usually made
them out of scraps
that people would send to us.
This little coat, she just
didn't have enough of one fabric
to make me a coat so that's
why she used the pieces
and that inspired her to tell
me the story from the bible.
So that's what this
coat -- we actually --
this coat, that little song and
the story has lived forever,
we even had a couple of movies
on TV about the little coat
and it got good ratings, so
it really shows people are
about family and they are about
love and it's good to feel
that warmth and that love
about parents because this day
and time we don't have
enough family stuff,
there is so much stuff going on
out there that little kids --
I love being able to touch
the kids and tell them stories
and for them to feel what
it was like back then
but it's really how it should
be now as far as the love
and acceptance and understanding
of not only just others
but your parents as well.
>> Well, we have also
a special announcement.
The Library of Congress
is partnering
with the Imagination Library
and to celebrate the program
and what we are doing, the last
Friday in every month is going
to be a special Imagination
Library story time.
>> Yay!
>> And they will be available
and it will be live streamed
to libraries throughout
the country
so people can participate.
We are delighted that you
have agreed to kick it off
and actually read right here
and start the Imagination
Library story time
at the Library of Congress.
>> Well I can do that.
I guess you want me to I guess
you want me to read the coat
of many colors book, right?
>> And we would love for
you to read this book!
>> Are we going down?
>> I think we're going
to go down because --
>> Is there a chair there?
Oh, they're going to have me
come down there, so I will be --
you be careful, hold on to
me and I'll hold on to him.
Okay. Hello!
Hello! Hello!
Hello kiddies!
You want me to read
a book to you?
You do? Well I'm gonna!
I gotta get my book lady
glasses on though so I can see!
How's that?
Do I look like the
book lady now?
Hi. This is called --
it says Dolly Parton,
that's my name and
what's your name?
Nice to see you, Sammy.
This says "coat of many colors"
and it's got the little
girl that's supposed to me
when I little wearing
her coat of many colors.
Let me find my real page here.
So it starts with all these
pretty pictures of my mom
and my dad and my pretty
pictures of my mom and my dad
and brothers and So it starts
with all these my brothers
and sisters in here so this says
"Back through the years I
go wanderin' once again back
to the seasons of my youth.
I recall a box of rags
that someone gave us
and how my momma put
those rags to use.
There were rags of many colors
but every piece was small.
I didn't have a coat and it
was way down in the fall.
So momma sewed the rags
together, she sewed every piece
with love and made my
coat of many colors
that I was so proud of.
As momma sewed she told a story
from the Bible she had read
about a coat of many colors
Joseph wore and then she said,
I hope this coat will bring
you good luck and happiness.
And I couldn't wait to wear it,
and momma blessed
it with a kiss.
So with patches on my britches
and holes in both my shoes,
in my coat of many colors
I hurried off to school.
Just to find the others laughing
and making fun of me in my coat
of many colors that
momma made for me.
In my coat of many colors
that my momma made for me,
made only from rags but
I wore it so proudly!
Although we had no money,
I was rich as I could be,
in my coat of many
colors momma made for me.
So with patches my britches
and holes in both my shoes,
in my coat of many colors
I hurried off to school.
Just to find the others
laughing and making fun of me,
in my coat of many colors
that momma made for me.
And I couldn't understand that,
because I felt I was rich!
I told 'em of the love
momma sewed in every stitch.
I even told 'em all that story
momma told me while she sewed
and why my coat of many
colors was worth more
than all their clothes.
But they didn't understand it
and I tried to make them see
that one is only poor
only if they choose to be.
It's true we had no money,
but I was rich as I could be
in my coat of many
colors momma made for me.
'Cuz momma made it just for me.
The end. Ta da.
(Applause) Did you like that?
O.K. so there's your
coat of many colors.
I'm going to go back up
on stage for a minute.
minute.
>> O.K. So here we are
>> That was so nice!
>> Dr. Hayden I thought, well,
I got to that part I thought
why not sing that little part
in case they hadn't heard that.
>> Well, not only
will the Library
of Congress have the 100
million 100 millionth book,
all the young people today
who have heard the
story, you're going
>> Well, not only
will the Library
of Congress have the
100 millionth book,
all the young people today
who have heard the story,
you're going to get your own
copy of a "Coat of many colors
>> Well, not only
will the Library
of Congress have the
100 millionth book,
all the young people today
who have heard the story,
you're going to get your own
copy of a "Coat of many colors".
>> Yes, you are!
>> You can take it when
you leave and you're going
to have a special CD, something
that you can play with the music
and you can hear Ms.
Parton's voice, too,
so we are glad you
could be here.
Remember, reading is fun, so we
have Remember, reading is fun,
so we have the book lady
and the library lady
and a new partnership with
the Imagination Library.
>> Yes, we do!
Thank you, everyone!
(Applause.)
>> All right, are
we heading out?
>> We're going to head
out and give out books.
>> Thank you everybody?
>> Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.